okay today I'm going to talk to you
about a reflex arc so all a reflex arc
is is a fast involuntary response to a
stimulus which means that we can avoid
or hopefully avoid damaging ourselves so
the example that we're going to look at
is the involuntary response and
voluntary gist meaning I'm not choosing
to do it happens without me even
thinking of when I put if I accidentally
put my hand on the rings of a hot tub
so if imagine the hop was on and I act
simple my hand on it my hand pulls away
without me even having to think about it
so it's a really really rapid quick
response now we're gonna see what is
going on in the nervous system in order
for that to happen so first of all let
me just draw my finger which is here and
here are the rings of the hub that I'm
accidentally putting my finger on now in
this particular example the hot hub we
call a stimulus because that is the
thing that I am going to detect now in
my finger I have lots of these things
called receptors now receptors receive a
signal so it's my receptors that detect
a change in the environment and my
receptors detect that this thing here is
hot so I put my finger on the hot hub
the hub is the stimulus receptors in my
finger detect that that is really hot
now in order for anything to happen we
need to send this information to the
central nervous system so in this
particular instance when we're dealing
with reflex arcs we don't send the
information all the way up to the brain
now the reason why that is we don't want
to send it all the way up to the brain
because it will take too long so instead
we send it to another part of the
central nervous system other than the
brain which is the spinal cord so our
spinal cord is also part of a central
nervous system and this is involved in
reflexes so a stimulus is ticked by the
receptors
now the receptors send a signal down a
type of neuron call
a sensory neurone because this is what
this is the neuron that we are sensing
we are sensing this stimulus so it
travels down a sensory neuron to the
central nervous system in particular the
spinal cord now within the spinal cord
we have a second neuron there's three
different neurons involved the sensory
new one is the first one within the
spinal cord we have another type of
neuron called a relay neuron
now the way I remember this relay neuron
is if you think about a relay race what
happens in a relay race is the baton
gets passed from one person to another
as they as they complete the race the
relay neuron passes the message from one
neuron to another neuron so it's passing
that message on a little bit like in a
relay race and the relay neuron is
entirely within the spinal cord within
the central nervous system so we then
pass it on to the third type of neuron
which is called a motor neuron now let's
think about what we're trying to do the
whole purpose of this is to get our
finger away from that harmful stimulus
as fast as possible so we need this
signal to be sent to muscle so the
muscle can contract and pull my finger
away so my muscle can pull my whole arm
away so here's just a diagram here to
show the muscle in my arm
now the muscle is referred to as an
effector so the effector within a reflex
arc is anything that's going to where we
have our effect which is to contract so
you don't mind of this neuron here is
called a motor neuron now the way I
remember motor neuron is begins with an
M and it's normally attached to a muscle
that's gonna cause movement so there's a
nice way of remembering it so as soon as
this as soon as the signal travels down
this motor neuron to this effector the
effector will contract and it
move my finger away remember it's really
important that it's really fast because
the longer that my fingers on the hub
the more that it's getting damaged
that's why in a reflex arc it would take
too long for that signal to travel all
the way up to the brain then us to think
oh wait a minute I need to move my hand
and then descend it so this is why it
goes to the spinal cord and not the
brain
so just to recap let's just write it
down at the bottom the different stages
involved so to begin with we have our
harmful stimulus for example our harbour
what we then have is a receptor which
receives that signal so the receptors
are in my skin my skin what we then have
is a sensory neuron
I remember sensory because I'm sensing
that particular stimulus I then go into
my central nervous system and I have a
relay neuron in my spinal cord the relay
neurons just going to pass this signal
on after my real a neuron it travels
straight to a motor neuron so my motor
neurone is going to be attached to a
muscle and involved in movement after my
motor neuron it's attached to an
effector usually a muscle but this could
be a gland for example and finally what
I get is my response and my response in
this particular instance is to contract
to pull my finger away so that's how
reflex arcs work thank you